there is no more guy I'd rather be in a
room with than this [ __ ] right here
well first of all there's this song the
fun uncle the fun annoying are the
unknowing the fun uncle that you like
when you're six and then when you turn
14 you're like [ __ ] uncle scatman
isn't coming is he
what ha ha ha you know what I mean dude
come on bro I mean I would love to be in
a room with this guy Jesus Christ dude
there's one song that it did the guy is
so [ __ ] high what's it called I got I
gotta find this for you guys yeah this
is it dude you're so high
I mean don't need an intro for this cat
man's world that's not a place oh my god
dude I'm telling you right now there's
there's another one though what's the
[ __ ] one I used to have it because it
was so funny dude it was on the album
scat man's world here song of Scotland
was in it I mean that everything is
Scotland with this guy Depp this is it
this is where he really [ __ ] lost his
mind
[Music]
okay
what everybody's equal that we're all
telling true
the Society of Scotland is composed of
very loving caring people who have never
even heard a political corruption a
class distinction a war and all the
other stuff that goes on 0:01 is equal
in Scanlan okay really driving that
point home then there's a bunch of kids
singing
scat world okay
it's nothing also doesn't mean [ __ ]
on people cool it's a German yeah we
listen to Scott world but it means
something so different to us we love
listening to it and [ __ ] all over
our spouses
[Music]